so this is how the kleptocracy works. We actually
have a really great example now that we can
look at. Donald Trump was so out
that his friend Roger Stone, who depending
on when you ask him, he barely knows, was
to be sentenced for possibly seven to nine
years that he personally intervened and all
of a sudden the sentencing recommendations
have been changed. The prosecutors have quit
in a fury and we have ourselves a very nice
little case study in the unhinged, the even
more on hinge Trump that we can expect to
see if he gets reelected to another first,
uh, to another four years. So the way that
it went down is that Trump went crazy on Twitter,
clearly tampered with the justice system and
Roger Stone now is going to get himself a
far shorter prison sentence for his crimes.
Federal prosecutors told the court Monday
that seven to nine years is the right range
that they would like to see for the crimes
that Roger Stone committed and was convicted
of, which are witness tampering and lying
to Congress.
Now remember, the prosecutors make a recommendation,
the defense will get a chance to state its
case and ultimately a judge will decide what
the sentence is going to be. Trump went nuts
at the Mir recommendation from the prosecutors
tweeting quote, this is a horrible and very
unfair situation. The real crimes were on
the other side as nothing happens to them.
Cannot allow this miscarriage of justice.
Now understand that when Donald Trump is referring
to people on the other side, he's talking
about about people who haven't been charged
with a crime, haven't been tried, and certainly
haven't been convicted of anything. So Trump
is saying the fact that people who I believe
did something wrong, but who haven't even
been accused of anything by the justice system,
the fact that they aren't going to prison
is a justification for Roger Stone going to
prison for a far shorter amount of time.
This is crazy authoritarianism. This is the
stuff of dictators. Now following Donald Trump's
middle of the night tweet, which he sent right
around 2:00 AM on Tuesday morning, the justice
department department suddenly decides we're
going to overrule the prosecutors who are
recommending seven to nine years. According
to Huffington post, all four federal prosecutors
who ran the Roger Stone trial then abruptly
dropped out of the case on Tuesday after senior
department of justice leadership intervened
to take the rare step of walking back the
prosecutor's sentencing recommendation. This
is not normal. This gets us to Tuesday afternoon
and as HuffPost says, the U S attorney's office
for DC filed a new recommendation asking that
stone, who is, of course a Trump advisor,
be sentenced to prison, but not suggesting
any particular length of time. Don't be tricked
by Trump or anybody around him. This is very
irregular. This is our justice system being
subjugated by the oval office for political
reasons successfully.
The prosecutors are resigning and this is
the unhinged Trump that we predicted because
he gets away with everything and it's going
to get much worse if he is reelected. We know
that Trump's acquittal from impeachment has
emboldened him. We know that Trump essentially
getting away with everything in the Mueller
investigation has emboldened him. He will
do whatever he wants and why wouldn't he?
He's gotten away with everything that he's
tried. They are purging legal truth telling
impeachment witnesses. We talked about that
Monday. This includes Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Veneman. This includes ambassador to the European
union, Gordon Sunland, and now they're telling
the justice department shorter prison sentences
please, and they're not saying, please just
imagine if Donald Trump wins reelection. Nothing
will hold them back. This is how we continue
the authoritarian slide. We have to stop it
in November. This story, if it were under
Obama, if it were under any other presidency,
it would be wall to wall coverage for days.
The incredible overreach by the oval office,
but it's barely a blip. It got a little coverage.
We had the New Hampshire primary around the
same time. Okay. This is just the beginning.
If Donald Trump gets himself reelected in
November